Mark Zuckerberg on how to run a company
in 2023 this is a Wall Street Journal
story
uh Mark Zuckerberg has announced an
update vision for the company in a year
of efficiency focused on cutting costs
and improving productivity that this
comes after a year of slow growth and
economic uncertainty the company plans
to cut 10 000 jobs over multiple rounds
of layoffs while leaving an additional
5000 open positions unfilled it will
eliminate middle management and flatten
its corporate hierarchy by converting
many managers into employees with no
supervisory responsibilities in other
words an anarchy low priority projects
will be canceled and internal tools will
be strengthened to help software
Engineers write code faster the company
will also pause new remote work
applications and requests to transfer to
another office through the first half of
the year as some employees have
performed better in person however meta
is committed to allowing both remote and
hybrid work Tom thoughts I I found this
to be like the death of a Thousand Cuts
um he's pouring money into this hole
um called the Ukraine war I I mean um
and
um so he's doing that and then they've
laid off some people now wait a minute
we have to the year of efficiency it's
just a year of job Cuts he's trying to
align what was this bloated cost with
the
economic reality the revenue to bring in
cutting 10 000 jobs and closing 5 000
open jobs it's he's basically he's
showing that this company has been
completely caught out and now he's
having to walk back and re-optimize and
he's not getting any number one and the
reason I'm going to do that he's not
getting any traction on the metaverse
but actually they had a pretty good Q4
that showed signs of light that with the
right number of folks they still are a
volcano of AD money which is good but
the the humorous part for me is pausing
new remote work applications so let's
read that pause new remote work
applications no one is getting
permission to work remote anymore and
then some employees that perform better
in person and then then to to quell the
Revolt before it happens however we're
committed to allowing both remote and
hybrid work so so I I think I I think
Mark is sort of an enigma wrapped in a
contradiction these days Michael I I
don't know that listen I'm no Mark
Zuckerberg he knows his business in his
company infinitely better than I do but
from my understanding of social media
and social media Dynamics I don't know
how you turn the ship around because
once some uh internet
um social media site is regarded as kind
of outdated or you know Grandma it
becomes a lot harder to get the kids
which are what it's kind of like
cigarettes right you want that Young
Generation to kind of keep it going to
sustain it I've been on Facebook in a
couple of years I know for a lot I I got
I don't know Joe no if you go to use
Instagram or no I use Instagram
facebook.com Michael Miles you can see
my last post a couple years ago uh it
hasn't hurt it hasn't hurt my my uh why
haven't you though what's your what's
your reason I I was it drove me crazy
that he changed this so I couldn't see
everyone's updates in a reverse
chronological order that you're gonna
curate my feed for me it's like this is
what I want I want to see everyone who I
follow you'll see all their posts how
many fans you have on Facebook right now
I have no idea I'm sure thousands uh can
you see the number yeah well you don't
have a fan page so that's just your
personal dude you have a fan page or no
I don't have a fan page Michael I think
you ought to consider having a fan page
let somebody monitor it not even you
doing it have somebody add your Clips
only reason I'm saying this if it's not
important don't do it you you are a
brand that could generate an additional
10 to 20 a month off of Facebook if it's
not it's important to you don't worry
about it but you'll blow up on on
Facebook and their monetization is
actually working effectively but good
point to say who's even using that right
that's kind of what you're right exactly
yeah and it's certainly not like
something that's regarded as a Cutting
Edge or hip or anything like that it's
really how do you do that it's very hard
yeah how do you do that how do you how
do you Tom the question becomes he makes
a good point how do you make it cool
again right because to me you know you
know how sometimes uh a parent screwed
up with the kids and they try to win the
kids over and they lower the standards
well guys moving forward you don't have
to make your bet thank you that you
didn't you didn't improve your situation
here right hey moving forward babe in
our relationship I will be more you know
XYZ no no you didn't make yourself more
attractive I think there needs to be a
vision that's attractive to get a new
market Facebook is officially the
company that buys companies right before
they're about to blow up and that's the
brand yeah and you've talked about that
before but how do you make Facebook cool
again that's the trillion Auto question
I don't think you can because you know
those little um you know that they're on
t-shirts and everywhere and it shows
Evolution where you have the the primate
and then he slowly starts to stand up
and then he's walking well basically you
can look at social media like that and
you've got AOL then you have Friendster
then you got Myspace and you got
Facebook I don't think you go back I
think once a new generation decides that
that is the arcade social media has
proven let me say that as proven that
once a generation turns its back on the
prior and goes to forward that's it I
mean ask the people at Snapchat who are
sitting there every morning at church
praying for tick tock to be shut down
the United States so that they have a
chance yeah to be rejuvenated I don't
think you turn it around Pat and that's
why you hearing things like we're going
to the I think Mark knows it and that's
why he doubled down on the metaverse
call it dumb call it smart call it what
you will but he's doubling down because
he needs a new play and now they're
coming out and saying we're going to
make this um open format you know
messaging platform with interrelated uh
relevance to the messages okay so why
don't you just say you're trying to make
a Twitter competitor at some point
that's what you're working on in the
back room I don't think you can turn
back the clock yeah yeah so so I think
you can I think you can and I think you
believe you can as well but but I think
the the gift Tom uh uh the gift of doing
that Mark doesn't have okay just like
like you know you know what true social
needs first of all they need a trump uh
they needed the uh Elon to not buy
Twitter that screwed up truth social the
day he bought Twitter it's over with
right that was game over yep sure but
but take Cheryl Sandberg outside of
Facebook what's Facebook nothing think
take look at the names I'm about to tell
you take Cheryl Sandberg out it doesn't
have the valuation it has number two
take who's the guy that came from
Napster what was his name the the nah
take Sean Parker out what's the vision
Sean Parker was the vision okay Cheryl
Sandberg was the uh money ads the the
twins uh whatever the uh those guys were
the idea
uzuk is an operator and an Executor and
a driver that's what he'll do but he's
not that guy so I think he needs to find
the next give you a perfect idea most
people when you think about Fox News
you ask the average person Fox News
who's the founder of Fox News they're
going to think the guy that's the
founder of Fox News is who the murder no
no if you have Roger they have no idea
they have no idea no idea they have no
idea the guy's Australian with an
Australian accent Rupert Murdoch is an
Australian government an Australian
accent what took fate what took Fox to
be a behemoth was a guy named Roger
rails okay you take Roger Els out it's
not going to happen the best thing Zuck
could do right now the best things I
could do right now is stop coming up
with ideas it's not your strength
go find the biggest badass innovator
creative that wants to prove a point
give him a fat salary with a big upside
let them come in rather than coming up
with ideas go find your Roger rails go
find your next Amber go find your next
recruit this is recruiting season I
think the approach he's taken is not
going to work out because he's not a
vision guy he's an Executor and by the
way zucks are very very hard to find
very very hard to find there's a reason
why he's worth what he's worth but he
can go find the other guys they're out
there I don't know a single person and
obviously that's a very bad metric for
saying something like this I want to put
that coffee at who's on the metaverse or
spends time exactly and I am on my
friends are big influencers in very many
fields if I don't have one data point to
the contrary that says something yeah
yeah so anyway that's my I may be wrong
all I'm saying is go recruit a guy like
that you have plenty of money and
attract the platform to give it to
somebody and by the way that guy becomes
a savior just just 20 years ago not even
20 years ago 19 19
1976 when did Apple get started 72 or 76
it's uh what year did Apple get started
1971 what year does it say 76 okay 1970
April fools 1976 pretty wild so they get
started 76 and an accidental millionaire
book comes out trash and good jobs right
and then what happens to him he gets
fired and then Apple's about to die
Scully the guy that he brings from Pepsi
ends up getting firing him right jobs
goes to uh uh home fries what do you
call it a Pixar and he sells Pixar to
who Disney then Apple comes in he starts
working the next computer next Pro yes
so then they come in then they bring him
back and then boom it takes off I think
Facebook needs to go find
recruited Taliban so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]